breaking overnight North Korea
reportedly launched a long-range
ballistic missile that landed in Japan's
exclusive economic zone North Korean
leader Kim Jong-un is again sharing the
spotlight with his young daughter North
Korean State media reported the two
attended a soccer match Friday to
celebrate the birthday of Kim jong-un's
late father the public appearance is the
latest fueling speculation that the
leader is grooming his daughter for
succession she's already front and
center on a series of postal stamps
North Korea rolled out on Friday
Elizabeth Palmer has more
of eight new stamps commemorating North
Korea's ICBM launch Five feature Kim
jong-un's daughter
South Korean intelligence
when she first appeared hand in hand
with Dad inspecting the missile and then
at the launch in North Korea she's
referred to as precious or beloved
daughter it took the former basketball
star Dennis Rodman after visiting his
friend Kim Jong-un to leak her name to a
British newspaper in 2013. Jew a and now
a local news Outlet quoting Anonymous
North Korean officials is reporting that
girls in North Korea called UA are being
forced to change their names
in two months jua has gone from
invisible
to front and center
jua is thought to have two brothers but
they are nowhere in the picture
in 2020 Kim Jong-un starred in a
propaganda video on a white horse symbol
of and they're telling the family's
sacred duty to lead the charge into a
glorious future
so when the commentator at a huge
military display in February pointed out
that jua's favorite White Horse followed
her dads in the Cavalry parade
speculation ran wild but these are
actually our very first glimpses of
North Korea's next dictator for CBS
Saturday morning Elizabeth Palmer Seoul
South Korea
it really is wild and first so the two
brothers they don't even know where the
two brothers are
right we don't know how old she is how
old do you think she is she looks 10. oh
see I wouldn't say older I think it
looks twelve yeah I was gonna say 12 13.
Yeah Yeah official name not even
confirmed right
well maybe she'll be
um
a different a different kind of leader
thank you Dana I knew what you were
thinking yeah he knew right there I
didn't see video for riding the horse
soon yes yes just Galloping Galloping
off